it's a wishlist ready given the success
this remarkable success of jwst and the
fact it's already producing images that
are just stunning the world and its
science is only just beginning
I thought as a theorist who knows
nothing about astronomy
I would try and give a from what a wish
list of of what it I would like to try
and understand us see from jwst that
will help us cosmologists understand
both the universe as it is now but also
the early universe
it's glasses sea light in the infrared
we can't see infrared so why is that if
useful because in the very early
universe
which it can probe back to light was
emitted from hopefully the first
galaxies that were forming and the first
Stars within the first galaxies that
light probably is in the visible part of
the spectrum when it was emitted and in
maybe the UV part of the spectrum but
that's 13 billion years ago 13.4 13.5
billion years ago only a few hundred
million years after the big bang since
that time as it started on its Traverse
through the cosmos the universe has been
expanding and what happens is light that
experiences an expansion gets stretched
And So It Begins emitted in the visible
light but by the time it's reached us
some 13 billion years later it's been
stretched into the infrared
so no matter how good your Hubble Space
Telescope was or any of your telescopes
on Earth that can on that can see
visible light it would not be able to
see that light whereas jwst is
specifically been made so that the light
it picks up is infrared light in the
very early Universe one of the things
it's going to try and find that evidence
for is the first galaxies that were
forming it can see those Galaxies for me
it can see because it's got
spectrometers it can see the light and
then it can break it up into its
constituent parts and from that it can
see what elements are in those galaxies
early on so it's gaining information
about those elements from 13 plus
billion years ago but here's the key
thing that I'm particularly interested
in right not clearly if it conceived
back that far and no one else can
it can also see nearer and so it can see
galaxies forming 13 billion years ago
but it can see galaxies then as they
were say 10 billion years ago 6 billion
years ago 5 billion years ago and what
you're beginning to get is as long as
you're thinking about the same type of
galaxies you're beginning to understand
the evolution of those galaxies how does
a Galaxy evolve through time my hope
this is why it's a wish list is that the
the way a Galaxy evolves on its large
scales will depend on what the
background universe is doing how it's
expanding
where we know the universe is dominated
by one thing today
dark energy
but we don't know what that dark energy
is
we think it might be something that is a
constant energy contribution throughout
the Universe because the energy density
energy per unit volume that's called a
cosmological constant
but it may not it may be something that
has evolved over time and has become
much more significant today my hope is
that these two sort of paradigms one
where the dark energy is evolving in
time and one where it's effectively a
constant in time will lead to subtle but
measurable differences in how a Galaxy
evolves and so what you would need to do
is solve your numerical simulations in
both of these situations one where it's
evolving in time and one where it isn't
when you do numerical simulations you're
looking at lots and lots of potential
galaxies evolving you hopefully will see
some difference say for example in the
clustering of galaxies how many there
you form in a given region or you might
see something different in the size of
the galaxies because Dark Energy might
prevent the galaxies from collapsing
depending upon how strong it is in the
early universe so if you might find
galaxies are a bit bigger than you were
expecting if the DACA energy is evolving
in time and because jwst is able to
probe so far back and hopefully see lots
and lots of examples of very early
galaxies we'll maybe get some decent
statistics on say the size distribution
and the clustering of them those will be
parameters numbers which depend upon the
nature of the Dark Energy so I can't
give you a concrete prediction as to
what you might find my guess would be
with a cosmological constant that they
are going to be sort of
um maybe a bit bigger than without the
cosmological custom simply because it
its presence might be more significant
early on
okay so so I've got my galaxies I'm
trying to understand the Dynamics of
those then if I look at say the center
of a galaxy one thing we know about the
center of the Galaxy is every Galaxy
that's been observed has a supermassive
black hole in there Sagittarius A is the
famous one in the Milky Way and that's
got a mass of about a million times the
mass of the Sun the question is what
what's the seed what led into what
became the center of the Galaxy which
could then accrete enough matter to give
you a billion solar masses one
possibility is that the seed could have
come from the very early universe in the
very early Universe much earlier than
this there are these objects that could
be in principal form that are very
massive cosmic strings that can be small
Loops of string which can form and they
can have masses which are quite easily
big enough to accomplish this thing of
the seed Mass I have to admit they're
not the favorite way forward those
people that work on this day in day out
say no you don't need to be so exotic
you can work with standard sort of
astrophysics and pinch this tweak that a
little bit and you can get it but here's
the question right
imagine jwst
keeps seeing masses close to a million
solar masses back at 13.4 billion years
ago in other words those first galaxies
that are forming are already have this
supermassive black hole in the center
and imagine if they keep seeing it then
the question arises is there enough time
for you know that seed must have been
there using standard astrophysics or do
I need some other more exotic particle
physics origin which is where I would
come in and yeah that's what I'm looking
for so so the second thing on my wish
list is that we can begin to probe the
core of a galaxy and see how massive it
is as we go further and further back and
if so you eventually go far enough back
that you have you just simply haven't
had enough time
to form that from conventional
astrophysics that's my hope so the third
thing that I think I would really like
to understand is what happens to the
supernovae as I go back in time so this
type 1A supernovae which are the white
dwarves that that create enough matter
that they then can form a supernovae
they use as standard candles
and that's the way that we actually have
been determining how the universe is
accelerating one of the key ways but we
can only probe it at the moment out to a
certain distance scale a distant
redshift it's of order one and when you
look at the different models of dark
energy and ask what does this Luminosity
the brightness of these objects how does
it look as a function of the redshift
how far away all the models look fairly
similar out to a redshift of of one or
so but the models then begin to differ
quite considerably
once you go past the redshift of one
because they they experience the matter
dominated part of the universe
differently one is the dark energy is a
cosmodial constant it experiences the
dark its contribution to the overall
budget in a is a constant but the the
ones with the
um evolving equations of State they can
actually they'll tail off compared to
the cosmological constant
so what you will see is a turnaround
from the acceleration that we
experienced today as we go back in
redshift the universe stops accelerating
we're going back in time remember the
universe stops accelerating goes into
what's called a matter dominated
universe that's where the structures
form that transition from the
acceleration into the matter domination
relies on the type of dark energy
and I my hope my third part of the wish
list is that the jwst will actually find
enough supernovae going out through that
regime to find lots and lots I think so
that it will be able to definitively
give us the profile of the luminosity
and then we can fit it with our models
so that's sort of like you'll be able to
recalibrate those standard candles and
continue using them as standing continue
using them as standard candles all the
way out to a much deeper distance and
then that I think
will provide us with a really good
handle on whether or not the dark energy
is evolving in time or whether or not
it's a constant that would be a massive
result there is a fourth thing if you
which is kind of linked but it's a real
wish wish list
a wish squared there have been papers
recently which suggest there's another
type of standard candle that we could
think about and these are quasars right
quasars are supermassic black holes of
going berserk and they can be found at
really large red shoes I think there's a
lot of controversy whether they really
are standard candles but if there are if
there is a way of representing them as
standard candles then they that's
another way of probing deep into the
universe and jwst because it can see
these massive supermassive black holes
it'll be able to probe all the way out
to these large large red shifts you know
taking us back to 13 billion years
number five could it tell us something
about the nature of dark matter and the
nature of some of the supermassive stars
that might be present in the early
Universe supermassive Stars yeah there
could be really big stars that are
present that could in principle have
come been formed not from the sort of
material we're used to but from the
scale of fields arising from the very
early Universe from inflation and there
are stars that theorists like myself
have worked on called buzz on Stars
which are formed in the very early
Universe Axion stars is another type you
can make sure that there are the sort of
size that you expect of stars and the
question is could we see any evidence
for that in the very early Universe
which jwst might be picking up
one of the things I've taken from your
wish list is you really want to know how
different the dark energy regime was
back then yeah to what it's like now you
want to compare the two yeah why would
the dark energy regime be so different
back in the early early days okay okay
my own Prejudice is now coming in all
right uh I admit um I work on an area I
have done a lot of work on an area
called
um scaling Solutions
okay what does that mean that means I
have some field evolving and it evolves
in such a way that it gets it it mimics
whatever the background is doing
and in the early Universe just a very
brief reminder the early Universe sort
of has a radiation dominated period
where the energy density is dominated by
radiation then it goes into a matter
dominated area when the bulk of
structures form and then it comes into
the dark energy dominated regime where
we're accelerating this scale of field
type model has the property there it
just mimics whatever is dominating at
the time cosmological constant is a
constant all the way back here
in time this one remember I've I've had
it so that it it matches a cosmodial
constant today but earlier on it could
have been bigger because it was tracking
it's called tracking following the
matter then following the radiation
so this idea of being able to see the
influence over time
is coming from a a Prejudice of mine
that I think if there are scalar fields
in the early Universe they can have this
property which is a really nice property
it's called an attractor solution where
it finds what's dominating and it goes
I'll have a bit of that and it'll follow
it and then it switches and it says I'll
have a bit of that matter Dominator and
it follows that
and we we don't know if the universe did
that or not and I'm hoping you've hit
the come to the nucleus of it I'm hoping
jwst can see some evidence of it that's
what I would really like
what there is it's a remarkably
nondescript star I suspect it was chosen
probably because it's fairly boring
right it's not you know it's not so
bright that it would sort of blind the
telescope it's not so faint that they
wouldn't actually be able to use it to
focus the telescope with it's got no
companions so you can get a nice sharp
image of an individual style it's got a
cool name